how about we talk about what's actually
happening right now with with Mount
Rushmore honestly and I I secretly have
the stream open over here oh we got this
nothing's going on there they're all
just standing there
I mean culturally man oh yeah let's talk
about it yeah we're the first I bring
you this story my friends native tribal
leaders are calling for the removal of
Mount Rushmore well y'all can go pound
sand we're not gonna tear down Mount
Rushmore sorry I think we can easily
recognize they were bad things done in
the past for sure and we have done away
with those things for the most part and
we continue to do better so let's not
destroy Mount Rushmore that's nuts
but CNN starts us off with a very calm
and reasonable well it's the native
tribal leaders it's what they're
requesting and I got to be honest I
recognize why they're saying it for sure
look European settlers came to this
country there was war that was conflict
in fact in the Declaration of
Independence you know that one of the
cited reasons for independence was that
I don't want to mess this up but there
was conflict between Native Americans
and the colonists go and they felt like
the crown made it worse to put it very
pretty very very lightly you can read
the Declaration of Independence yourself
you should it's what 4th of July is
coming up that was one of the reasons
and they did not use kind words for the
Native Americans okay they used very
unkind words so it's it's it's there you
know and I can recognize why there are
people who native indigenous people who
are upset about all this yeah and then
you know what they have been for a long
time this isn't this isn't new it's just
cool for CNN to jump on the bandwagon
yeah so so here's the issue while I can
certainly respect the feelings of you
know there's bad history man mm-hmm
am I supposed to call it Japan right now
and start complaining about why my
family was forced to flee am I gonna do
that no I'm not gonna do that
am I gonna complain about any any object
or anything in that no I'm not gonna do
it I'm not gonna complain about the fact
that a lot of the bad laws in this
country which made it harder for my
family it existed and were put in place
by Democrats and others I'm gonna yeah
you know what well here we are and I'm
gonna keep my focus on the president
and say at least we have at least we
have the games we have right yeah
and you know what the way I see it is we
can't survive as a country if we demand
a pendulum swing if we if we demand
revenge all the time that's true if
someone is standing above you and they
agree to come down to an even playing
field you can't then say no no you have
to go down further that's my turn to go
up I'm right no no no if someone if
someone has the power and the wealth and
the control and they're like listen we
recognize equality and all that stuff so
we're gonna step down and level the
playing field you say thank you all
right yeah and they may still have
advantages and all that stuff but to
destroy something is going way in the
wrong direction but of course CNN they
just can't help themselves
first CNN just gives us the general news
which is okay the native tribal leaders
are concerned about upset about this and
I can respect that then we get this
story Trump set for another massive
event during national pandemic Oh
everything has to be wrong with
everything he does it's just oh man um
so many people are arguing about this
the protesting didn't cause a spike of
kovat and it's like okay if that's the
case what why does it matter that he's
having a rally exactly what's its
outdoors right what's the difference
it's a bunch of people marching together
all wearing masks okay cheating so
what's wrong with the protesting
lockdown also what's the difference I
mean your other than the cause the cause
is the only difference that's it the
words the words apparently black lives
matter is a magical phrase what you can
cure Cove it right that's right yeah
they say it slows down the spread well
now we have that that's Eric Garcetti of
LA has admitted the protests did cause a
spike Oh what happened
and I actually referenced that to the
the conversation I was having and of
course it was with someone who was from
LA and just started ripping the what is
it the mayor right ripping the mayor of
our town just like oh well he's he's
corrupt
so anything he says is is you can't even
trust it what he's saying it's like oh
all right well great because I read your
article and it didn't even have any
evidence to the
contrary I was just showing you this is
out there also doesn't that this is this
is just whatever fits their narrow I saw
this segment going around on Twitter
it's really truly remarkable CNN oh man
CNN's Leila Santiago Mount Rushmore a
monument of to slave owners on land
wrestled away from Native Americans da
think about what it is they're they're
arguing for you know I made the joke
before the segment about the logical
conclusion of all of this identity
social justice stuff is that we give all
executive authority on the planet two
one ultranumb yeah and so they're just
like a comatose disabled multiracial
whatever you name it every single every
single negative thing all balled into
one granted the sole global executive
authority over everything decisions they
can't actually make so nothing happens
but you take a look at what's going on
with with with Mount Rushmore and let's
be real about what the conclusion is do
we just send all of the white people
back to Europe that doesn't make any
sense do we dissolve the the
governmental charters of New York City
of Rapid City of Chicago
do we say you know what all white people
must be roof removed from government and
the Native Americans come and take
everything back I don't know I don't
think anybody who's out there fighting
the system really knows there's certain
protesters out there that want police
reform you know that's that's one of the
biggest things it's like okay I agree
with that police reform is okay you know
the Republicans actually brought a bill
to police reform and the Democrats
denied it you know what a surprise
you know but then then there's the other
people out there that are just ripping
now burning elk statues yeah what's what
did that help to to you what don't you
know did that hurt you the elk were the
original oppressors right yeah of course
that's right I don't get it
they were oppressing they were
oppressing the elk eat grass yeah I do
they do they pretty sure but but grass
though
yeah they graze yeah they eat like stuff
off the ate algae as well duck weed they
lick rocks there you go do they lick
rugs I'm just gonna go ahead and imagine
that the elk are actually vicious and
they eat squirrels and chipmunks and
small woodland creatures there we go
yeah because otherwise if they're just
herbivores I can only imagine them as
being like cutesy and happy and like
bouncing and frolicking big but if but
if we add in that they they kill small
cutesy creatures then we can imagine
them more snarling and evil they have
been known to attack moving vehicles the
alpha the Alpha elk there you go have
been known to attack humans also so I
don't know maybe are you sure maybe
they're fascists yeah ashes elk see are
you sure the elk were actually calm and
just grazing or was it actually more
like they were snarling and snatching up
squirrels and ripping them in half with
their vicious jaws the squirrels are
running and it was just total snow they
just Jenna just stomp on the squirrel
and just watch it
kill you know no reason did the elk
maybe heard the squirrels into an
encampment of sorts yeah maybe it's a
statue of an elk in Portland they burned
it down is a hundred twenty year old
statue came what is wrong with these
people I'm saying they don't know what
they don't know what they want but they
want to burn the system down so they
don't know what they'll get when the
system is actually gone you won't be
able to eat food you're not growing your
own food I know that you know part of me
just wants them to experience what they
ask for
I like because then we gonna be forcing
it upon the rest of us it's like no look
I I am vegan and I know it's a privilege
to be vegan in this world all these I'm
watching them all and they're all be
there they all have vegan and their
profile and I'm just like man you guys
you're the reason you're giving Feakins
a bad name because they they can't be
vegan if the world goes goes away you
got to start hunting your food do you
know how to hunt your own food right I
do rice and beans I I would I would if
the world went that way I could rice
aids they wouldn't they wouldn't last
nope it pisses me off dude right so
they're so privileged and they're icing
rice rice where you gonna get rice
you're gonna grow it you're gonna be a
farmer you're gonna be in a big rice
field you know how to grow rice you put
the rice in the water and rice you get
more of it yeah that's how it the rice
duplicates itself in water look I don't
know how to farm rice the point is it is
possible to be vegan if you have rice
fields and you can grow beans I have no
idea where beans are grown but rice and
beans does complaint contain as far as i
understanding is a complete amino chain
and it's actually like a massive portion
of
global you know foods food supply the
issue is these people come on man they
don't know how to grow rice or beans one
of the tent that they're the climate to
grow rice or beans and the rice and
beans they do eat is shipped around the
country and the world
they don't have the the work ethic - oh
man - farm their own food let alone that
would be what they had to do every
single day the internet would be gone
you'd have to actually work all day long
do you know what that feels like you
know I know they don't they having no
clue what it worked what it takes to
work all day long I already know it's
gonna happen oh man
tell me right now the revolution is
occurring in the Pacific Northwest yeah
the climate there is not great for
farming as far as I know no I mean I'm
sure there's some things that grow up
there that you can't eat here's what
will happen this whole area will secede
from the union there'll be a major
uprising and then they'll elect their
new leaders in the lull cheer and within
two weeks they'll run out of avocados
and there'll be another revolution and
there will be a demand to rejoin the
union and toast and well the toast
they'll still have you know they look at
their little group they'll make their
bread the bread machines they got flour
left over but avocados man those aren't
coming no those are like Maidan those
are gone in Mexico and the end
California but you're sure mostly so
it's if California joins them oh my god
that's how it happens what see it's not
just the Pacific Northwest but
California joins in and then they're
unstoppable they have an endless supply
of avocado to fuel
how about toast you know but once they
can't supply what once the food source
of avocados runs out and they all starve
to death then then the Union you know
the walks back in and just ghupat the
corpses and you know and then takes the
cities back mm-hmm and there's like just
a wasteland and there's their shelves
filled with all kinds of regular food
it's just once they run out of avocados
man that was it the Millennial
revolutionaries couldn't survive without
it
nope that was there I was there I was
there and they they they they're
scientists desperately try to synthesize
artificial avocado
like it it's like yeah dumping all of
their resources into it yeah we must
source our tits ever see the movie
Daybreakers yes
the vampires yeah trying to create fake
blood mmm that's what it is fake avocado
otherwise they can't sustain the
revolution no in all reality though I
could imagine a scenario where all these
protests kick off truckers don't want to
come in
you know and then non revolutionary
types start freaking out because there's
no avocado and now I'm being for real
now I mean it literally imagine with all
the riots going on in Portland in
Seattle truckers say I am NOT gonna
drive into that city when they're
defunding police I mean they're already
saying exactly right so now all of a
sudden this you know you got this decent
he's 29 he's got a man bun and he's
wearing you know his capri pants not
that there's anything wrong with the man
done he's got a v-neck he's wearing a
v-neck shirt with a long beard okay and
he's not a revolutionary man and he
walks in a local shop and he's like yo
can I get I'm gonna do chai latte and
you do with almond milk and I'll do the
avocado toast I'm sorry we're out of
akkad Oh out of avocado when are you
getting it back we're not because the
shipments won't come in because of the
riots and then I'll Sony goes he tears
all his hair out and then he just rips
his shirt off and he goes outside starts
punching an Tifa guys and then all of
you do this gll votes hardcore
ultra-nationalists ultra-nationalist the
guy merely puts on a proud boy shirt
he's like okay but no seriousness that
was amazing Tim very nice but that
tomato put it more seriously to go even
more serious than I was trying to be
before please do it when people people
don't realize that strawberries don't
grow where they come from right
blueberries mangoes these things are all
imported from other parts of the world
it's ridiculous in my opinion that we
actually do it now a lot of these people
thought a lot of environmental activists
understand the importance of eating
seasonal fruits and vegetables mm-hmm
because when you get strawberries in the
winter you got to understand where those
strawberries came from and how much
energy it took to get them there you
know burns a lot of fossil fuels and all
this other stuff once these people who
know nothing but wealth and comfort
let's be real man listen yep most of
them are wealthy it's not even about
that
it's about relative wealth and comfort
okay good point you know I I hear this
all the time that our parents you know
it's like it's like the first generation
where the kids will be worse off than
their parents were okay and I'm like
what makes you think that's true what
makes you think that we're worse off my
dad didn't have a cellphone you didn't
even have a TV get in the apartment the
mattress on the floor my dad had to work
all day long
yep all the time you know weekend's
could you pull his phone and and and
press a button and then ask a question
get an answer no there's a really funny
a comic that was made like eight years
ago and it was this was not meant to be
funny was meant to be serious it was
like three people are sitting on a couch
playing and tendo or something okay and
then someone said what was the year that
Lincoln was assassinated I don't know do
you guys know no I don't know either
huh then the next panel is like today
hey what year was looking assassinated
and the guy pulls up his phone and he's
like 1848 or whatever I don't know what
the actual year was like 65 or something
whatever the point was that we live in
an era where you've got a good library
anymore that's true no gotta pull up a
book you can just you just got it in the
internet so now we have a whole
generation of people who have nothing to
do that's true no service yeah so they
just make up some random purpose and now
they're complaining about how bad
everything is when it's better than it's
ever been
yep exactly and sort of been saying I
was here when you I do when you can have
pizza any time because they've put on a
bagel
yeah what happens when you disrupt the
system to the point where that goes away
and now if you experience the real world
once these people actually get a taste
of what it really what is really
required of you for survival man these
people's their eyes are gonna go full
Biden it's gonna pop blot everywhere as
I was telling that story about the
Occupy people who got the farm mm-hmm oh
no they did not like that yeah they
actually work they'd get up and do work
and that takes I mean you you can't
chill you can't relax and just shoot
whatever you want to do on the internet
it's like no there is no internet you
want time for a night you have to work
from the when you wake up so you get too
tired to keep working and you go to
sleep and it continues over and that's
how farmers do we've got farmers out
there that's that's what they do they
farm all day long and they work to get
us food
you didn't think about they don't even
think about it the person you told me
about that that millennial that believed
food appeared in the store well that's
where food came from I don't know if
they believed the food just appeared
there I certainly certainly seemed they
never thought beyond where does the food
actually come from let alone all the
different options that are there and all
the different lines of you know the
wheels moving in society to give us
these comforts that we have oh man I
tell you he nuts when I try talking to
some people so this guy I know posted
something on Facebook where he's like I
kid you not he argued instead of
reopening businesses just to pay
everyone and I was like why don't you
just give everyone money so they can
generate stuff on their own government
is so dumb they should just like give
people money and then they'll have money
so they can have okay they can eat
wherever they spend the money if there's
no nothing open that's what I said and I
was like so so I was like let's break
things down for a second let's just
let's just put some some quick math
right huh the value of the dollar is
based on many things but basically the
value is based on what you get for it
all right and right now in the United
States you get a lot for a dollar
there's food tools you know services
let's just use those sue x y&z like been
quantified right and I said what happens
if you shut down 90% of all businesses
well now the dollar can only get you
things from essential services right now
if you're somebody who already has food
what does the money mean for you nothing
nothing so let's let's say you own your
house you got to pay taxes right okay so
you're gonna you got it you got to pay
something if you're if you're someone
who has the majority of your needs met
then someone's like hey I'll give you
ten dollars for that Apple you're like
well I need the Apple okay I'll keep you
up I can't buy anything the ten dollars
in a long enough shutdown the money
becomes worthless because there's
nothing you can do with it right so I'm
like if the government's cos are
printing out money and giving it to
people but everything's closed at a
certain point people are like I don't
need this what happened in Venezuela
yeah and that the trunk loads of money
they can't buy an apple with well that's
that's that's a whole lot of other
problems no you're right you're right
sure but they were they it's amazing how
Venezuela was extremely
see one of the most oil-rich nations in
the planet mm-hmm and then they were
like you get a bunch of well-off you
know relatively poor people mm-hmm and
then they just burn everything to the
ground there you go that's what they
want for us and you know I got I gotta
say man you know I'm not actually all
that worried about it you know it's
funny cuz I feel like I'm worried for
them well cuz you have a van that you're
gonna live in a van hey hey hey hey hey
I was I was on the Joe Rogan podcast
yeah and we were we were laughing about
and I said if you keep going down this
path here it's gonna happen I'm buying a
van and then everybody laughed and I
think I'm joking mm you but said van
then I remember when actually when I
told Joe I literally did have the van he
what you really did was like yeah I did
it
you know I built the van it's got it's
got a thousand amp hours in it it's got
solar panels things pretty buff this
thing Abaza van if with the solar panels
on it we'll never run out of power for
all the basic uses like as long as it's
sunny out
yeah right right right but technically
it will never run out of power with a
thousand amp hours with the monitor with
general electrical outlet usage if I had
a bunch of things plugged in a laptop ah
we did the math and the amount of power
that it holds will easily sustain
everything in the event that it's too
cloudy or too dark yeah but with general
sunlight it charges faster than it
discharges now just need to figure out
food and water right so I parked the van
somewhere now I really don't think it's
gonna come to that to be honest no but
the the point is if everything just
broke down mm-hmm I'm not worried about
myself I'm worried about them I feel
like when I'm telling these people to
stop doing it it's not because I'm
worried about what's gonna happen to me
I agree that's right I feel the same way
I know how to do that we got three
recurve bows right there some broad
heads we go hunt some wild boar mm-hmm
and you'd have two axes in the loincloth
and you'd be running it down and just
take it out
actually no I'm I'm really accurate with
a bow I'd probably prefer the bow and
that's situation yeah yeah people don't
know that about you you actually did
archery I did yeah so Adam would be
alive proficient the male
Katniss Everdeen taken out the wild game
and we have a little love you know the
more you know little van village a
little bit and these people like the
sound of that these people would turn
out like Morlocks or the I am Legend
creatures you know they're gonna be in
New York running around like they
wouldn't last that long dude well they
would by eating each other okay yeah
which would in turn make them crazier
and then they'd eat the crazy and then
in turn get them more crazy yeah it's
like then they get like the shake the
[ __ ] hook of Italy oh yeah pull out your
hand he's like I'm good yeah have you
ever seen Pandorum I think so
what maybe I watched it no you haven't
is that that's the one you were watching
and I don't know that so basically
they're on a colony ship leaving Earth
to go very far away and they're in
hypersleep there's must be a high
percent for a few hundred years
this dude wakes up through a default
release of hypersleep so it's not proper
procedure so he's all messed up okay but
then there's these weird humanoid
cannibalistic creatures that hunt humans
on the ship and edom mmm it basically
turns out that like spoiler yeah I mean
the movies twenty-something years old
hey boiler man spoiler you don't spoil
it it turns out in it so that there's
there was a there's an evolutionary
virus to help humans adapt to the new
planet mm-hmm
but because it was released to people on
the ship they adapted by becoming
cannibalistic humanoid monsters that
could eat other humans the only way to
survive so that's that what I imagined
would happen an taifa you know okay it'd
actually be really funny to do like a
short story or film or like video game
where it's like in a hundred years
there's like walled off cities of
regular humans who have like you know
there's the official flag is the Gadsden
flag it's like the national flag of the
tribes yeah but you go outside the walls
and you must beware and Tifa
and if they've evolved into like like
Gollum from Lord of the Rings and
they're like cannibalistic and walking
and you go out there it's very dangerous
you well we are animals people like to
forget that or think that we're
different but it's like no we're we're
mammals we we are there's animals on
this planet and they the alpha male is
usually the one smarter who wins we've
separated we separated ourselves from
from evolution yeah you know it used to
be that when one species
overcame another it was through
scheduled adaptations then humans gotten
intelligent and were able to overcome
any everything yeah basically everything
so boom like we are we are masterful
predators man yep
so here's what I find funny about the
ante for stuff and all this weirdo
revolutionary garbage like you do these
people have any skills no no other other
than a company on the internet they're
very good at that I doubt those very
good that's they have skills and
admittedly they're the best they're the
best yeah ring if they went they've got
a PhD in ringing yeah REE amen
no one is better at complaining on the
internet than the woke left that's true
they've gotten down to an art you got to
do work to live I don't care what you
believe in so so I'm thinking about this
and I'm like they claim to represent the
working class
they don't these are not these people
are overwhelmingly post grads and
graduates you know who make 100k plus a
year mm-hmm and they're demanding
subsidies from the government to forgive
their loans like why are we going to
subsidize the wealthiest people you know
there are the people the highest
salaries it's true meanwhile regular
working-class people are like you know
importantly 40 year old white dude who
like fixes toilets for a living does
plumbing mm-hmm and it's it's decent
income for a lot of these guys doesn't
even have to be a white dude that why
you got to be racist bro I'm just
talking about I got I gotta be like you
Joe the Plumber number Joe the Plumber
no but seriously anyone anyone could be
in the trades I and I worked in the
trades for a while and I'm nice oh it
doesn't matter who you are there was all
different types of people in there
I'm just of course of course the point
I'm making is these scrawny college
students who think they're smarter than
you do not represent anybody but
themselves it's true so they're calling
cops traitors and stuff it's like bro
that cop is more working-class than you
are I know yeah now they're like abolish
the police unions and I'm like okay okay
you're for open borders which 10 years
ago was the was the the ultra right-wing
according to Bernie Sanders you know the
libertarian right-wing industrialists
sure but my private company you say a
Facebook okay that's a very right-wing
traditionally thing and you're all
scrawny upper-class rich people who
want to subsidize what is this why are
they the left what do they really want
nothing that I don't yeah exactly
there's no time they want to be they
want everything they want to be kings
you know why they hate Trump they want
things handed to them that their sense
of entitlement knows no bounds I think
one of the reasons they hate Trump is
that in one way they see he's a
reflection of them okay i feei view
Trump as somebody who really wants
approval and definitely does and this is
one of the one of the things that uh
that I'd been saying was a big mistake
of the Democrats Trump wants you to love
him mm-hmm he puts his name on top of
buildings and big bold letters yeah
clearly one thing he really wants is the
adoration of the people yeah if the
Democrats just like placated him he'd
have given him whatever they wanted
there was even like a gun control
compromise if they just said wow Trump
you're you're a really great and
effective leader a good leader would do
this he'd be like oh definitely I'm the
best everybody agrees yeah let's let's
let's go with this I need to get a lot
of compromise done but the Democrats
didn't want to do that they want it to
hate him you know and just attack him
probably because he's messing up their
game yeah the all this money that
they're making off of the deals almost
putting in Hillary was putting a TPP
would have been a win default a lot his
big corporation yeah exactly and even
Bernie opposed it thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you